l'ordre du jour appelle le vote
solennelle sur le projet de loi relatif
à l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable donc avant de
passer au vote nous avons des
explications de vote de 5 minutes avec
un orateur par groupe et le premier
orateur va être monsieur Sébastien
jumelle pour le groupe gauche-démocrate
et républicaine
madame la présidente madame la ministre
comme à chaque fois qu'une question
importante nous est posée le groupe GDR
sa composante communiste sa composante
ultramarine se prononce en fonction du
texte et du contexte le contexte vous le
connaissez c'est celui d'une crise
énergétique sans précédent depuis
1973 d'une crise qui fait mal au vide
qui fragilise l'économie réelle celle
des boulangers et des 12 millions de
Français qui chaque matin vont acheter
leurs pains mais aussi jusque nos
industries qui est créatrices d'emploi
et de richesse dont la compétitivité est
considérablement bousculé
le contexte c'est les factures c'est sur
les factures que ça fait mal
2023 est l'année de tous les dangers
pour nos restaurateurs nos commerces nos
PME qui risquent devant cette crise de
l'énergie de mettre la clé sous la porte
prenez garde le quoiqu'il en coûte
devient pour un très grand nombre de
Français le quoi qu'il en chauffe
pourquoi en sommes-nous arrivés là parce
que depuis 20 ans vous laissez le marché
faire son oeuvre parce que vous refusez
de mettre en oeuvre le bouclier
tarifaire qui est le seul qui vaille les
tarifs réglementés pour les usagers pour
les acteurs économiques pour des
communes et parce que malgré
l'écoulementons réitérer
inefficace vous êtes incapable de taper
du point sur la table des négociations
de Bruxelles pour obtenir des allemands
comme l'ont décidé les Espagnols et les
Portugais de décorer les le gaz de la
construction du prix de l'électricité
alors que nous avons devant nous un
immense défi climatique que le président
semble découvrir à la faveur de ses vœux
alors que tout cela impliquerait de
rassembler des Français autour d'une
politique énergétique publique clair
souveraine décarbonée équilibré consenti
vous conservez cette idée fixe cette
religion qui vous habite d'une certaine
manière votre obstination à vouloir
rassurer les marchés plutôt que de
rassurer les Français cette phrase vous
en doutez prend pour nous une
signification particulière le jour où
vous annoncez vouloir mettre en oeuvre
votre réforme des retraites dont les
Français savent qu'elle va toucher les
classes moyennes les ouvriers les
employés les moins diplômés tous ceux
qui ne sont pas nés avec une cuillère en
argent dans la bouche le texte sur les
énergies renouvelables qui est soumis à
notre approbation ne répond évidemment à
aucune de ces questions fondamentales
vous ne tirez aucun enseignement aucun
bilan des 20 ans de libéralisation qui
ont transformé l'énergie en marchandise
vous ne tirez aucun enseignement aucun
bilan de trop d’années ou d’état refusé
en matière énergétique d'être un état
stratège planificateur au service d'un
mix énergétique équilibré intelligent
vous vous contentez avec un calendrier
inversé incohérent accélération des ENR
accélération du nucléaire avant
l'élaboration d'une loi de une formation
sur l'énergie de vouloir accélérer à
tout prix n'importe comment avec
n'importe qui en laissant le marché
faire ses courses
malgré vos velléités de séduction de
l'opposition voir dans dedormissement de
l'opposition nous concédons ici ou là
quelques amendements pour corriger le
texte nous considérons que vous avez
cédé sur des miettes le texte reste flou
sur le quant à la capacité des communes
instances de démocratie vivante de
proximité à peser jusqu'au bout dans les
outils de planification le texte reste
en panne malgré l'amendement que nous
avons obtenu avec notre collègue
Delphine bateau sur les seuils de
saturation qui auraient permis de ne
plus développer de NR là où il y en a
trop là où il y en a beaucoup dans les
hauts de France ou dans le nord de la
Seine-Maritime en rétablissant la raison
impérative majeure une ligne rouge
contre la vie du Parlement a été
franchie le texte permettra tout et
n'importe quoi au détriment des règles
environnementales et la qualité
architecturales patrimoniale qui font la
France permettez-moi de vous dire que le
jour où les tréportés portent un recours
devant la justice européenne que votre
refus de prendre en compte les conflits
d'usage et notamment de sacraliser la
bande côtière permettant de donner un
signe à la pêche artisanale est un
mauvais signal votre impuissance à
incarner un état qui protège et
flagrante votre incapacité à planifier
le développement des EnR par la
puissance publique pour structurer des
filières made in France pour reconnaître
comme nos collègues ultramarins ont
proposé l'extraordinaire potentiel que
représentait les outre-mer pour innover
en matière de NR montre bien que votre
sujet n'était pas là votre sujet était
d'accélérer la dérégulation de l'énergie
toutes ces raisons et peut-être bien
d'autres si le temps me le permettait
conduiront le groupe Geder à refuser ce
blanc saint de refuser ce blanc saint ce
mardi 10 janvier où vous déclarez après
deux crises majeures la guerre sociale
aux Français avec votre réforme des
retraites toutes ces raisons nous
conduisent à voter contre votre mauvais
projet
la parole est à Madame Nathalie Bassir
pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoires
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues année après année
rapport après rapport les scientifiques
nous alèrent sur les causes et les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
et ce depuis les années 1970 la crise
climatique était prévisible et prévue
qui peut prétendre le contraire et le
dérèglement climatique est déjà à
l'oeuvre sans surprise puisque les
politiques à l'échelle mondiale n'ont
pas été à la hauteur de l'enjeu alors
aujourd'hui si nous sommes inquiets face
à un avenir incertain
nous savons aussi l'urgence à agir nous
le savons il n'existe pas de réponse
unique à la problématique du changement
climatique ni à celle de la transition
énergétique répondre à l'urgence passera
nécessairement par un programme de
développement du nucléaire mais aussi et
surtout par le déploiement d'énergie
renouvelable partout sur le territoire
c'est d'ailleurs l'objectif affiché par
ce projet de loi mais le texte final
permet-il d'accélérer vraiment pour
notre groupe qui a une fibre écologique
affirmée il y a eu au cours de l'examen
de ce texte des occasions manquées tout
d'abord concernant le volet partage de
la valeur nous comprenons que la baisse
forfaitaire sur les factures des
riverains et suscité des débats
philosophiques nous étions pour notre
part partisans d'une approche
pragmatique permettre aux rares pardon
directement concernés de tirer profit de
l'éolienne installé à côté de chez eux
et c'était selon nous un bon moyen de
rendre les renouvelables acceptables
voire désirable la majorité de cette
hémicycle a tragé à trancher en faveur
d'un partage de la valeur à l'impact
plus indirect au profit des communes
nous en prenons acte autre regret le
dispositif de planification qui reste
trop lacunaire il devait répondre en
deux à deux priorités pour notre groupe
instaurer une planification globale du
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
et favoriser l'acceptabilité en tenant
compte des efforts fournis par certains
territoires sur ces deux points le texte
est trop timide il n'y a pas de
planification cohérent puisque les zones
d'accélération et les zones d'exclusion
ne seront pas définis en même temps les
porteurs de projets pourront s'installer
dans des zones tierces
quant à la capacité de définir des zones
d'exclusion elle reste limitée aux
communes disposant de documents
d'urbanisme dans la ruralité dans les
petites communes les élus ne pourront
pas toujours s'opposer à l'installation
de nouveaux projets même si leur
territoire sont saturés par les mains
des déceptions en face sur les zones non
interconnectées là où il existe un
impératif d'autonomie énergétique nous
aurions aimé davantage de volontarisme
politique pour déployer les énergies
renouvelables rien pour garantir des
appels d'offres réguliers pas assez
d'engagement pour développer nos
capacités de stockage sur ces sujets il
nous reste donc à vous donner
rendez-vous à la prochaine programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie pour avancer
ces quelques critiques faites nous
considérons que dans ces grandes lignes
le texte final permettra des avancées
sur le fond certaines dispositions vont
dans le bon sens la facilitation d'accès
offensiers non agricoles pour les
solaires sur les abords de route
d'autoroute de voies ferrées de friche
et de parking est un bon exemple de
mesure consensuelles de même les
dispositifs de planification de l'éolien
en mer sont essentiels pour rattraper le
retard accumulé en France un seul parc
est en service alors que des pays comme
la Belgique les Pays-Bas compte déjà des
centaines de ma concernant les zones non
interconnectés enfin des mesures
essentielles ont été actées pour adopter
les dispositions du texte au
spécificités des outre-mer et de la
Corse une majorité à notre initiative
d'ailleurs la limitation des PPA à la
France hexagonale l'abaissement du seuil
et l'adaptation de l'obligation
d'installation de panneaux
photovoltaïques sur les parkings en
outre-mer en sont des exemples dans la
méthode enfin la ministre les
rapporteurs ont su se montrer davantage
à l'écoute ce texte plus que d'autres a
fait l'objet d'un dialogue avec les
oppositions à l'heure de faire le bidon
nous sommes face à un projet de loi
incomplet certes on peine d'ailleurs à
évaluer si permettra une réelle
accélération du déploiement des énergies
renouvelables mais il représente une
avancée par rapport à l'existant et
une planification faite comme elle est
faite aujourd'hui vaut mieux que la loi
de la jungle qui prévaut aujourd'hui
dans certains territoires aussi une
partie des députés du groupe liotte
s'absiendra tandis qu'une majorité
votera en faveur de ce projet de loi je
vous remercie je vous remercie ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Damien Adam pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les présidents de commission
madame messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues 95%
, 95%, c'était hier le pourcentage de
production d'électricité décarbonée de
la France ce chiffre parmi les meilleurs
d'Europe témoignent de la pertinence des
choix français opérés notamment avec le
plan Messmer de 1974 qui visait à
limiter la dépendance au pétrole à
travers la construction d'un parc
nucléaire et une série de mesures de
sobriété énergétiques et oui déjà à
l'époque aujourd'hui la situation est
différente mais notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles est encore présente et
nous devons lancer un plan Messmer du
21e siècle pour faire de la France la
première nation européenne à sortir
complètement des énergies fossiles ce
plan Messmer du 21e siècle il repose sur
trois piliers le premier est une loi de
programmation énergie climat prévue pour
le deuxième semestre 2023 elle fixera le
cap technologie par technologie et
secteur pas secteur pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 le deuxième
pilier c'est un projet de loi pour la
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires qui sera étudiée par le
Parlement dans les prochaines semaines
et le troisième pilier sur lequel nous
nous exprimons aujourd'hui par notre
vote c'est notre volonté de développer
les énergies renouvelables dans notre
pays et passer ainsi de 95% de
production d'électricité d'origine des
carbonée à 100%. car il y a un paradoxe
si nous avons la production
d'électricité parmi la plus décarbonée
d'Europe nous sommes malgré tout en
retard sur le développement des énergies
renouvelables et ce projet de loi en
temps répondre à ce paradoxe en votant
pour ce projet de loi vous votez pour
utiliser le foncier disponible des
parkings de plus de 1500 mètres carrés
pour y installer des ombrières
photovoltaïques et ainsi doubler la
surface dédiée à l'énergie solaire en
votant pour ce projet de loi vous votez
également pour équiper les surfaces déjà
artificialisées qui sont les bords des
routes et les autoroutes en panneaux
photovoltaïques en votant pour ce projet
de loi vous votez pour un développement
raisonné et concerté de l'éolien
terrestre en votant pour ce projet de
loi vous VO pour faciliter le
développement de l'éolien en mer avec
une planification à 10 ans en votant
pour ce projet de loi enfin vous votez
également pour plusieurs mesures en
faveur de la méthanisation de
l'hydroélectricité de l'hydrolien
fluvial et de la géothermie nos débats
tend au Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale
ont permis de nombreuses avancées et un
travail t'enrichissement inédit qui fait
honneur à notre démocratie à l'Assemblée
nationale 351 amendements ont été
adoptés en séance soit près de 10% des
amendements totaux déposés sur le texte
donc 42 venant du groupe socialiste 33
du groupe écologiste 17 du groupe les
républicains et 16 du groupe yacht fier
de ce texte fier du travail accompli par
notre assemblée est fier de porter le
développement des énergies renouvelables
le groupe Renaissance votera donc pour
ce projet de loi qui permettra à la
France de se doter d'un outil
supplémentaire pour assurer sa
souveraineté énergétique je vous
remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Nicolas maisonnet
pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Messieurs les Présidents des commissions
sur les rapporteur chers collègues alors
que de l'autre côté du rein le rêve
éolien s'achève par la réouverture de 27
centrales à charbon et par le doublement
de la capacité de production des
centrales à gaz l'Assemblée nationale
s'apprête à voter un texte qui marquera
ce mandat dans son décalage avec la
réalité totale tout au long des débats
nous députés du rassemblement national
l'avant eu de 16 de dénoncer la
direction que prenait ce projet de loi
une direction qui ne repose sur aucun
fondement scientifique ni économique ou
écologique une direction qui est celle
de l'obstination de l'idéologie et de la
compromission politique si l'erreur est
humaine persévérer diabolique chers
collègues la première absurdité de ce
texte c'est qu'il se fonde sur une
programmation énergétique obsolète qui
n'a toujours pas été révisée qui ne
correspond pas aux besoins en
électricité du pays notamment
bien la perspective d'une
réindustrialisation dans une soumission
totale à l'Allemagne et à Bruxelles
Emmanuel Macron persistent et signes
nous devrions perdre ainsi l'un de nos
derniers avantages comparatifs changer
de modèle énergétique et copier celui de
nos voisins pourtant pendant près de 40
ans la France a vécu sans crainte les
coupures de courant bénéficiant de
l'électricité sur abondante peu cher et
même décarbonée de ces centrales
nucléaires et hydroélectriques mais ce
projet de loi confirme que l'heure n'est
plus à la rationalité que propose-t-il
de développer les énergies renouvelables
la réponse est non il s'agit de
développer des énergies intermittentes
fatal un véritable fardeau pour notre
réseau électrique parce qu'elles sont
coûteuses parce qu'elle multiplie les
pointes de production d'électricité et
nous mettent à la merci d'un blackout
chaque hiver il va bien falloir répondre
à cette question que nous vous avons
posé mille fois pendant les débats
sans vent ni soleil comment fait-on la
solution utilisée par nos voisins et
toute trouvée ouvrir ou réactiver des
centrales à gaz ou à charbon
inutile d'en dire plus tant la situation
est tubusque chers collègues à cela
s'ajoute le très faiblement de ces
installations qui implique dans
l'installer dans des proportions
hallucinantes ce que vous voulez pas
dire aux Français c'est qu'à l'exception
de quelques endroits plus privilégiés
comme par exemple le Touquet des hommes
urbaines c'est la quasi-totalité du
territoire qui sera impacté des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires
partout et à perte de vue activité
touristique agriculture pêche de
multiples secteurs vont payer les
conséquences des milliers de personnes
souvent issues de milieu modestes
verront la valeur foncière de leur bien
s'effondrer de territoires entiers déjà
marginalisés vont perdre le peu
d'attractivité qui leur restait ce
projet de loi c'est aussi le sacrifice
de la biodiversité lorsque l'on voit les
milliers d'hectares de pairs rasés dans
les Landes ou la plaine de la Somme
éventrée par des câbles électriques et
les maldéoliennes on ne peut que
craindre le pire lorsque l'on sait que
ce texte a pour visé d'accélérer ces
pratiques est-ce que cette loi aura un
effet positif sur le climat ou notre
souveraineté énergétique non bien au
contraire notre électricité déjà des
carbonées les énergies intermittent nous
rendront davantage dépendant du gaz et
du charbon je ne me parle même pas des
quantités de matériaux nécessaires à
leur construction et de l'absence
d'industrie nationale qui vont nous
plonger dans de nouvelles dépendances
tout en subventionnant des
multinationales qui nous fourniront des
éoliennes allemandes des panneaux
solaires chinois le gouvernement méprise
la vie dériverains en refusant une
distance minimale pour les parcs au sort
et surtout un instaurant la raison
impératif des intérêts publics majeurs
véritable rouleau compresseur vous allez
aggraver la fracture entre les
métropoles et la France périphérique
refusant le décroissance de la
les mensonges climato-hypostries
hypocrite de la macronie le
rassemblement national a démontré qu'il
était le seul parti à proposer une vraie
transition énergétique dans ce texte
rien ou presque rien sur la géothermie
et la biomasse qui pourrait être des
solutions intéressantes rien ou presque
rien soit hydraulique qui fait largement
partie de la solution et qu'il
nécessiterait davantage d'investissement
nous avons eu de 16 vous le répéter face
aux intérêts particuliers aux pressions
des lobbies aux errants aux ingérences
étrangères face aux injonctions
bruxelloises nous sommes de ceux qui
disent non de ceux qui refusent de
massacrer nos campagnes et notre
patrimoine de ceux qui refusent de
détruire notre modèle électrique
performant de ceux qui n'abandonnent pas
les intérêts nationaux de ceux qui ne
sacrifient pas la biodiversité nos
paysages pour des délires idéologiques
alors
chers collègues face à des
parlementaires qui se comportent comme
de véritables VRP nous appelons tous les
députés courageux à voter comme nous
contre ce projet de loi nous n'en sommes
qu'au début du scandale et le temps
donnera raison croyez-moi les Français
verront qui a défendu leurs intérêts
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Maxime l'aîné
pour la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous avons
abordé ces débats de manière
constructive puisque comme vous le savez
notre groupe elle est finie UPS visent
l'objectif d'un scénario 100%
renouvelable à l'horizon 2050 tel que
définit par RTA nous avons donc
pleinement joué le jeu en déposant plus
de 200 amendements pour tenter
d'améliorer un texte pour le moins
confus malheureusement l'état actuel ce
n'est pas une loi d'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable qui
est soumise à nos votes mais une loi
d'accélération de la marchandisation des
ENR nous passons à côté de l'objectif
alors que les enjeux sont considérables
premièrement il convient résolument de
sortir de l'exploitation des énergies
fossiles et il n'y a ici que le
président Macron pour en avoir pas su
prédire l'accélération du réchauffement
climatique et ses conséquences
désastreuses deuxièmement je le dis au
député qui ont dilapidé leur temps de
parole en interminables tunnel
anti-éolien comme au gouvernement qui
s'obstine à décliner la décision
présidentielle unilatérale de relance de
l'atome de nouveau projet nucléaire ne
nous permettront pas de répondre aux
urgences énergétiques et climatiques de
court terme le développement des EnR
n'est pas une option mais une nécessité
troisièmement la France reste à la
traîne et l'objectif d'un minimum de 33%
de NR à l'horizon 2030 figureront dans
l'actuel programmation plural de
l'énergie est encore loin d'être atteint
pour autant par leur capacité de
foisonnement ces énergies variables sont
une clé de notre souveraineté face à ces
défis le texte issu de notre première
lecture présente de nombreux manques
tout d'abord il ne définit aucun
objectif chiffré renvoyant cette
question à la nouvelle PPE qui ne sera
discuté qu'en fin d'année au mieux il
faut dire que en même temps et dans le
désordre des débats sont menés à la fois
sur la construction de nouveaux EPR et
sur le mix énergétique dans la plus
grande confidentialité ensuite aucune
disposition ne vient renforcer les
moyens des autorités environnementales
pour instruire les dossiers enfin ce
texte n'engage aucune structuration des
filières industrielles et de formation
quel est le bilan de nos débats
concernant l'énergie solaire nous avons
contribué à renforcement des obligations
d'ombrières sur les parkings de plus de
1500 mètres carrés ainsi que les
sanctions référentes nous regrettons
pourtant la non réintroduction de
l'article 11 TER sur la couverture des
bâtiments existants qui constituaient
aux yeux des associations une avancée
significative concernant la
grivevoltaïsme nous actons les timides
efforts de définition pour autant sur ce
sujet comme sur celui de la
méthanisation nous affirmons qu'aucune
terre cultivable ne doit être détournée
de ses fonctions nourricières
d'autant que les surfaces non agricoles
permettraient déjà de dépasser les
objectifs à atteindre en matière de
photovoltaïques sur les enjeux de
biodiversité
l'entourloupe de la réintroduction de la
ripem dans la pire de ces versions nous
laisser craindre des atteintes
irréversibles au vivant pourtant le
changement de destination des sols reste
la principale cause de perte de
biodiversité sur la participation du
public qui constitue pour nous la clé du
développement des EnR vous avez refusé
que la population soit associée dès la
phase de définition des zones
d'accélération votre planification reste
d'ailleurs défaillante voire contre
performante puisque largement improvisée
d'abord vous avez rétabli un quasi droit
de veto pour les mers dans une procédure
sans fin et ce malgré nos propositions
qui ont pourtant convaincu sur de
nombreux bancs ensuite ce pseudo
planification se résume à la création de
zone aquabon en effet rien ne nous dit
ni que ces zones seront réellement
créées ni que des znr se déploieront sur
celle-ci ni même qu'elles ne pourront
pas s'installer ailleurs alors à quoi
bon votre partage de la valeur ne nous
convainc pas non plus si nous avons
gagné la suppression de la ristourne sur
la facture pour les riverains le partage
de la valeur devrait passer
prioritairement par une répartition plus
équilibrée de l'hyper à destination des
communes enfin ce projet de loi
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un marché
libéralisé en permettant le
développement d'une multitude de
contrats de grès agréés cette
généralisation met en danger la
péréquation nationale tarifaire puisque
chacun perdra un prix différent en
fonction de son contrat c'est-à-dire de
son poids économique à l'inverse parce
que l'énergie est un bien commun
d'intérêt général trop précieux pour
être laissé à la main invisible du
marché qui favorise un déploiement
anarchique des ENR nous prenons la
création d'un véritable pôle public de
l'énergie cela passe par une
généralisation des contrats de long
terme à prix fixe selon une grille
tarifaire fondée sur les coûts de
production et la création d'un opérateur
public unique et national d'achat de la
production d'électricité ce qui
permettrait outre le retour à des tarifs
réglementés pour tous ménage entreprise
et collectivités pour conclure ne disons
que ce texte est malheureux
immatérialisation du fameux en même
temps jupitérien dans ce qu'il peut
donner de pire d'un côté parce qu'il
manque d'ambition voir qu'il freinera le
développement des énergies renouvelables
de l'autre parce qu'il ouvre la
possibilité d'un développement chaotique
dans lequel de gros acteurs privés
imposeront leur accaparement du
territoire aux populations tenues à
l'écart et aux élus pris à la gorge nous
espérons sincèrement que ce projet de
loi puisse évoluer dans le bon sens en
CMP mais en l'état le groupe LFI UPS
votera contre ce texte
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel Maquet
pour le groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente Messieurs les
Présidents et rapporteurs madame la
ministre mes chers collègues au terme
d'une discussion passionnante mais sans
surprise le groupe les républicains le
sentiment que l'examen de ce texte
restera une occasion manquée au moment
où la France redevient un portatrice
d'électricité au moment où plan de la
menace de la rupture d'alimentation au
moment où le choix allemand du gaz et du
charbon s'impose à nous ce texte aurait
pu nous apporter les clés d'une
souveraineté retrouvée madame la
ministre et nous l'avons dénoncé ce
texte prépare une véritable OPA sur nos
territoires ruraux et littoraux par les
promoteurs sans scrupules du
renouvelable et ce pour quel résultat
une énergie ni efficace ni pilotable ni
abondante ni prévisible vous le savez
mes chers collègues les énergies
renouvelables induisent des coûts très
élevés à la fois sur le réseau et sur
l'environnement et au final surtout sur
le pouvoir d'achat des Français c'est un
gâchi environnemental à plus d'un titre
d'abord parce que les énergies
renouvelables tous azimuts ne sont pas
la panacée pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique comment
allez-vous convaincre les usagers
d'énergie thermique de franchir le pas
de la transition électrique si les jours
s'en vont et sans soleil c'est le gaz
russe le charbon allemand et le gaz de
schiste américain qui prennent les
relais en libérant massivement du
carbone et des microparticules quand on
veut madame la ministre sauver la
planète du réchauffement climatique le
pragmatisme ce n'est pas l'énergie
renouvelable mais l'énergie bas carbone
l'autre aspect de ce gâchis
environnemental et la bétonisation des
millions de kilomètres carrés de nos
campagnes et de notre littoral la
qualité des paysages est un bien commun
immatériel pourtant vous leur imposez la
plus importante mutation depuis
l'invention de l'agriculture avec 15000
éoliennes supplémentaires qui viendront
industrialiser des zones remarquables
jusqu'à présent préservées quand on sait
les impacts sur les écosystèmes au
moment même ou un accord historique a
été signé à la COP 15 pour protéger la
biodiversité c'est une contradiction
grave alors que vous imposez par
ailleurs aux Français le zéro
artificialisation nette dans nos
territoires ruraux
les éoliennes qui pourront être
installés grâce à ce texte auprès
représente mes chers collègues
l'équivalent de la surface totale d'un
département français 50 fois la surface
de Paris ce n'est pas rassurant bien au
contraire c'était effrayant notre
objectif commun d'atteindre 100 millions
de touristes par année pour 7 % de notre
pays B pourra-t-il être tenu si ces
paysages magnifiques qui font la France
sont saccagés enfin ce texte est un
gâchis politique car malgré madame la
ministre va trouver sur la forme vos
actes montrent clairement que tout était
tout était décider à l'avance sur les
points qui auraient pu nous faire
réfléchir à une co-construction de ce
texte à vos côtés vous avez été
résolument intransigeante nous voulions
mieux protéger les riverains en
augmentant la distance minimale entre
les éoliennes et les habitations
celles-ci vous le savez n'a pas évolué
depuis 2011 elle est toujours de 500
mètres alors que la hauteur moyenne des
éoliennes a augmenté plus de 60 mètres
92% des Français ils sont pourtant
favorables fin de non-recevoir nous
voulions protéger les littoraux qui font
notre richesse patrimoniale et
touristique des mains d'éoliennes aussi
haut que la Tour Eiffel en éloignant les
parcs de notre littoral les côtes sont
aussi les zones touristiques de France
et la bande des 12000 nautiques la plus
riche en biodiversité cette zone est
aussi le périmètre de travail de nos
parts de nos marins pêcheurs qu'il faut
entendre et surtout protéger là encore
c'est une fin de non-recevoir nous
voulions que la reconnaissance
d'intérêts publiques majeur soit un
principe général accordé à tous les
projets industriels de France à nos yeux
quand on veut réindustrier les et la
France il y a aucune raison de réserver
ce privilège aux seules énergies
renouvelables là encore ça a été une fin
de non-recevoir nous voulions rendre
Homer le contrôle total sur
l'aménagement de leur commune en
imposant la vie conforme des conseils
municipaux sur tous les projets comme le
souhaite pour cent des Français là
encore c'était une fin de non-recevoir
en accordant aucune considération sur
revendications vous préparez les
conditions de la colère des Français qui
vivent sur nos territoires ruraux face à
votre dogmatisme le groupe les
républicains exprime avec cohérence des
choix clairs l'électricité bakarbonne
plutôt que le gaz russe le charbon le
pétrole les ingénieurs nucléaires
français plutôt que les conglomérases
industriels danois et chinois la
souveraineté plutôt que la dépendance la
sobriété budgétaire plutôt que le quoi
qu'il en coûte sur le dos des Français
quoi qu'en disent le président de la
République depuis 20 ans tous ceux qui
écoutent la science pouvaient non
seulement prévoir la crise climatique
mais surtout pérenniser ce qu'avait fait
de la France l'avant-garde de la lutte
climatique l'énergie nucléaire et
puisque nous sommes pour la protection
du climat avant tout et favorable à la
production de l'énergie battlebone le
groupe les républicains s'opposera
l'adoption de ce mauvais texte
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno millienne
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les présidents de commission
madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues après deux semaines de
débat riche et intenses je suis fier de
me retrouver à nouveau devant vous pour
défendre l'adoption d'un texte crucial
pour l'avenir énergétique et écologique
de la France crucial tout d'abord pour
préserver notre planète des effets du
dérèglement climatique à l'oeuvre chaque
année plus menaçant à ce titre nous
avons veillé tout au long de ce texte à
articuler les enjeux climatiques à ceux
de préservation de la biodiversité nos
politiques publiques doivent se
coordonner et ignorer en rien les liens
étroits entre climat et biodiversité
crucial ensuite au regard de notre
souveraineté car nous ne pouvons pas
accepter que notre la consommation
d'énergie finale dépendent toujours plus
actuellement aux deux tiers des énergies
fossiles produites par des puissances
étrangères l'actualité récente nous
rappelle l'urgence de garantir notre
indépendance et notre autonomie
énergétique ces deux semaines de débat
ont démontré la richesse de notre
assemblée et l'existence d'un chemin
celui d'un travail transpartisan au
service des Français près de la moitié
des amendements adoptés sur ce texte
proviennent des groupes d'opposition je
tiens donc à féliciter avec force madame
la ministre pour sa capacité d'écoute sa
détermination à trouver des compromis et
donc son sens de l'intérêt collectif
nous avons donc construit un texte
équilibré qui permettra de déployer au
plus vite le potentiel de nos
territoires en matière d'énergie
renouvelables aussi nombreuses
soient-elles en effet il est impératif
de diversifier nos modes de production
renouvelables en développant davantage
la méthanisation la géothermie
l'hydrogène ou les réseaux de chaleur et
de froid il faut accélérer partout où
cela est possible ce texte permet de
réduire efficacement les délais pour la
mise en oeuvre des projets d'énergie
renouvelables grâce à une simplification
des profits procédures sans toutefois
escamotée l'indispensable participation
du public participation à laquelle notre
groupe est attaché
5 ans pour la construction d'un parc
solaire 7 pour un parc éolien terrestre
10 pour un parc éolien en mer ces
chiffres seront bientôt obsolètes et
fortement réduit grâce à ce texte pour
cela l'accélération des projets par
l'échelon le plus local et la clé le
national doit fixer le cap les objectifs
informés des potentiels énergétiques de
chacun et puis c'est aux élus locaux
d'être au cœur du dispositif de cette
planification énergétique il en
reviendra ainsi d'identifier les zones
les plus propices pour accueillir des
projets d'énergie renouvelables car qui
de mieux placé pour le savoir si la
proposition sénatoriale du veto des mers
n'était pas une bonne solution les
maires n'en voulaient d'ailleurs pas
eux-mêmes je le dis clairement aucune
zone d'accélération ne pourrait être
identifiée sans la vie conforme de la
commune concernée l'éolien en mer
également bénéficiera en fin d'une
planification permettant de rattraper
son retard
cette planification sera prévue sur 10
ans pour les quatre façades maritimes
notamment grâce à une cartographie qui
permettra d'identifier les zones
d'accélération à horizon 2050 nous
sommes bien sûr conscients de la
nécessité de favoriser l'acceptabilité
des éoliennes en mer c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons renforcé la
possibilité de saisir la Commission
nationale du débat public sur l'éolien
nous pouvons enfin nous réjouir d'avoir
introduit des mesures pour la
préservation de la biodiversité marine
concernant le déploiement de l'énergie
solaire le groupe démocrate se satisfait
de l'ambition apportée pour la
libération du foncier comme par exemple
l'extension de l'obligation pour les
parkings extérieurs existants
d'installer des panneaux solaires ou
encore en bordure d'autoroute et de
voies ferrées je tiens à ce titre à
saluer le travail de notre rapporteur
haut de Luquet nous sommes également
satisfaits des mesures votées contre en
concernant pardon la grille voltaïsme il
était essentiel d'encadrer ces pratiques
en les conditionnant une activité
agricole ces choses faites en outre nous
avons obtenu quel état fixer un volume
de surface pouvant être mobilisés pour
le solaire au sol de la même manière une
installation photovoltaïque ne pourra
pas être possible au sol sans avoir été
préalablement mis en place sur une
surface de 40% minimum en toiture ces
installations ne seront autorisées que
sur des terres réputées incultes ou non
exploitées depuis au moins 10 ans dans
le but de permettre le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables sans menacer la
production agricole avec aussi des
garanties financières pour s'assurer de
la réversibilité des installations
agrivoltaïques nous saluons aussi
l'adoption du meilleur partage de la
valeur créée par l'exploitation des ENR
qui permettra aux communes développement
des projets de voir leur facture baissée
ou d'en tirer des ressources pour
financer des projets de rénovation
énergétique ce texte largement
co-construit avec les groupes
d'opposition apporte ainsi une réponse
pragmatique et ambitieuse au défi imposé
par le dérèglement climatique et c'est
avec beaucoup de fierté que le groupe
démocrate le votera madame la ministre
si les républicains et le rassemblement
national j'en finis madame la Présidente
le rassemblement national votre
rencontre par dogmatisme anti-olien
J'espère de tout cœur que nos colocs de
gauche soutiendront ou à tout le moins
n'empêcheront pas la doption de ce texte
auquel ces membres ont largement
contribué j'espère que vous aussi
collègues écologiste malgré votre
annonce de la semaine dernière qui m'a
surprise vous voterai ce texte que vous
avez contribué à écrire avec l'adoption
de plus d'une trentaine d'amendements je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
donc je vous indique que je fais
annoncer le scrutin dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale et la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane delautraite pour le
groupe socialiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues ce 10 janvier n'est pas
seulement le moment du vote solennel de
votre projet de loi c'est aussi le jour
de la présentation du projet de réforme
des retraites voulues par le Président
de la République un projet
inutile et injuste que nous combattrons
avec vigueur unis avec l'ensemble de la
gauche et des syndicats cependant madame
la ministre nous faisons bien la part
des choses et seul l'intérêt général
dicte notre vote sur la forme vous aviez
annoncé vouloir co-construire ce texte
avec les groupes de bonne volontés
malgré les divergences à l'expérience de
ces derniers mois nous étions
légitimement sceptiques dans les faits
nos échanges ont été nombreux réguliers
exigeants parfois difficiles mais nous
avons su avancer et trouver des
compromis sur le fond madame la ministre
lorsque nous nous étions rencontrés en
août dernier nous avions listé les
manques de votre texte et nos lignes
nous avions pointé du doigt un texte
très insuffisant sur l'ambition muer sur
la planification et mal orienté sur le
partage de la valeur au cours des débats
en commission et en séance ce sont 70
amendements de notre groupe qui ont été
adoptés ainsi sur la base de ces
propositions et de celle du rapporteur
nous avons structuré un processus de
planification territoriale qui associe
le bloc communal et le Scott les
communautés de communes en dialogue avec
le préfet à l'échelle départementale
sont la clé du dispositif ces hommages
seront conformes à la PPE régionalisée
nous avons aussi renforcé les
compétences des EPCI en matière de
production et de portage des projets de
NR trois points doivent cependant être
réglés en commission mixte paritaire la
rationalisation de la composition de la
commission départementale le niveau de
contraintes à imposer aux communes qui
refusent de s'inscrire dans ce schéma et
de caractère obligatoire à terme
d'accélération nous avons également
obtenu un renforcement des obligations
de solarisation des toitures des
bâtiments tertiaires et des parkings
même si nous restons sur notre fin
s'agissant du bâti existant nous avons
en bonne intelligence avec notre
collègue Eric bottorell et son groupe
construit un cadre de régulation
exigeant pour la grivoltaïsme et le
solaire au sol enfin nous avons remis le
partage de la valeur au bon niveau celui
du territoire et pour le financement de
projet inscrits dans la transition
énergétique la préservation de
l'environnement et la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique nous avons
également obtenu
l'adoption de nombreuses dispositions
nouvelles corrigeant des angles morts du
texte ainsi toutes les entreprises
publiques devront présenter un plan de
valorisation énergétique de leur foncier
dans le même esprit nous allons
mobiliser le potentiel multi énergie du
réseau de voies navigables de France
comme les aujourd'hui celui concéder à
la Compagnie nationale du Rhône de plus
nous allons concentrer d'effort de
production et de consommation d'énergie
renouvelable des entreprises sur des
zones d'activités économiques en levant
les contraintes environnementales sur
ces espèces artificialisées pour en
faire des parcs à énergie positives afin
de structurer une filière française et
européenne susceptibles de répondre aux
enjeux de massification et de
souveraineté énergétiques nous faisons
de la commande publique en levier
essentiel enfin nous avons obtenu la
reconnaissance d'une méthanisation 100%
des fluant agricoles dans le régime
tarifaire et fiscal sera fiscé en loi de
finance notre groupe votre a donc pour
ce projet de loi car nous avons non
seulement pu lever nos lignes rouges
mais également y apporter des
dispositions conséquentes
nous avons cependant deux déceptions
majeures nous regrettons que sur
l'article 4 les avancées envisagées
étaient balayées par un retour de
dernière minute à la rédaction initiale
qui ne saurait figurés en l'état dans le
texte final nous regrettons également la
faiblesse des dispositions pour les
territoires ultramarins dans le
potentiel et pourtant gigantesque notre
groupe avait pour ambition d'en faire
des territoires 100% ENR enfin nous vous
mettons en garde madame la ministre en
vue de la CMP nos lignes rouges
subsistent si un accord en CMP devait
intervenir il ne devra pas se faire sur
un texte dilué mais précisé et enrichi
autrement et nous le disons d'emblée
nous n'aurons aucun état d'âme à rejeter
ses conclusions notre vote favorable nos
vocaux pour le produit équilibré et
loyal de nos débats de décembre il n'est
pas un acquis il est aussi un engagement
à poursuivre le débat fondamental de la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
travaillons ensemble d'ici la CMP pour
financer finaliser une rédaction qui
nous permet d'aboutir à un texte de
consensus équilibré et ambitieux je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue
[Applaudissements]
un sentier beau pour le groupe horizon
merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs
messieurs les présidents de commission
mes chers collègues il y a presque un an
lors de son discours de Belfort le
président avait annoncé une ambition
forte faire en 30 ans de la France le
premier grand pays du monde à sortir de
la dépendance aux énergies fossiles et
renforcer notre indépendance énergétique
la proposition relative de loi par nos
relatives aux énergies renouvelables que
nous voterons dans quelques minutes
constitue constitue ainsi la première
marche vers une France plus verte plus
souveraine une France qui respecte ses
engagements nationaux européens
internationaux ce texte mes chers
collègues aussi celui qui nous permettra
d'aller plus vite en matière énergétique
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique pour diversifier nos apports
énergétiques tout en respectant et dans
le respect de nos territoires et nous
concitoyens ce texte est également le
premier grand chantier en matière
énergétique car vous le savez notre
stratégie doit être pluriel et nous
devrions nous saisir de savoir faire en
matière nucléaire que la France a su
développer depuis des décennies dans
cette stratégie et avant d'examiner la
proposition de loi relative au nucléaire
des si peu il nous faut donc mettre en
œuvre ce premier grand chantier au terme
de 9 jours d'examens sciences publiques
et plus de 60 heures de débats ce sont
donc 351 amendements qui ont été adoptés
de l'ensemble des bancs de cette
hémicycle les débats furent mouvementée
mais tous pour toutes et tous c'est 60
heures du débat nous ont permis
d'enrichir ce texte fondamental et de
proposer aux Françaises et Français une
loi qui répond de défi de notre temps à
ce titre je tiens à remercier la
ministre pour son écoute l'ensemble des
rapports ainsi que les présidents
commission pour leur travail et leur
qualité et leur engagement le groupe
Horizon est apparenté a été
particulièrement investi sur son projet
de loi avec 130 amendements pour déposer
donc 58 ont été adoptés notre objectif a
été d'aller plus loin en termes de
planification et de territorisation deux
éléments qui doivent être au corps au
cœur du déploiement de toutes les
énergies renouvelables l'article 3
travaillé par notre rapporteur que je
salue Henry alfonsdari constitue à ce
titre leur Saturne de cette stratégie de
planification de nombreuses dispositions
étaient prises afin de faciliter un
concertation avec les populations et
l'amélioration de la subtilité des
projets nous avons souhaité que j'ai du
coup ils élu locaux soient au premier
rang s'il vous plaît pour écouter les
merci
merci monsieur le président soit au
premier rang de la transition
énergétique désormais ces derniers les
élus locaux pourront instaurer des zones
d'accélération et d'exclusion de projets
d'énergie renouvelables ils pourront
également s'appuyer sur un référent
préfectoral chargé d'accompagner au plus
près les acteurs du terrain aussi parce
que cet accompagnant a été essentiel le
groupe Horizon a obtenu la mise en place
d'un dispositif de soutien économique à
l'implantation des projets dans les
zones d'accélération par ailleurs nous
avons également souhaité apporter des
améliorations concernant le
développement des projets
d'autoconsommation collective
d'utilisation d'hydrogène bas carbone ou
encore expérimenter la production
d'azote à la ferme qui permettra de
soutenir le monde agricole français
accélération simplification et partage
la valeur ont ainsi été les maîtres mots
de la majorité présidentielle lors de
l'examen de ce texte toutefois accélérer
ne doit être synonyme de précipitation
c'est pour c'est pourquoi nous avons par
exemple souhaité que le texte prévoit la
création d'un observatoire des énergies
renouvelables et de la biodiversité
c'est aussi pourquoi nous avons souhaité
renforcer le rôle de nos territoires et
assurer un partage la valeur aux
collectivités et leurs administrer enfin
un élément majeur doit être souligné
déployer les énergies renouvelables
c'est aussi contribuer économiquement à
la vie de notre pays une contribution
qui doit non seulement qui non seulement
fera l'objet d'un partage la valeur mais
qui contribuer contribuer à laceptivité
des énergies renouvelables favoriser
l'émergence d'une filière ou plusieurs
filières d'excellence mais aussi assurer
une énergie souveraine qui restera un
prix acceptable pour l'ensemble des
citoyens et citoyennes nous en sommes
convaincus c'est l'ensemble avec nos
petites ensemble avec nos élus locaux et
en écoutant nos territoires que nous y
arriverons en votant ce texte nous
actons une première phrase nous allons
dans le bon sens pour assurer à nos
concitoyens et concitoyens
d'avoir une énergie pour l'ensemble de
leurs usages du quotidien et surtout une
énergie acceptable je rappelle que les
énergies renouvelables en 2022 contribué
à plus de 9 milliards près de 9
milliards dans le budget de l'État et
sera d'autant plus en 2023 les énergies
renouvelables sont une chance pour nos
territoires pour la compétitivité de nos
entreprises mais aussi et surtout pour
les générations d'aujourd'hui et de
demain nous devons prévoir l'avenir
dit maintenant le groupe Horizon est
apparenté votre a donc largement faveur
de ce projet de loi je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
il y a un dernier orateur je vous
remercie vraiment de l'écouter de faire
silence parce que il y a un brouhaha qui
est vraiment trop important donc
Monsieur Charles Fournier pour le groupe
écologique
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chère collègues en proposant un
texte d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables le gouvernement donnait
enfin l'opportunité de traduire
l'impérius nécessité d'avancer sur ce
développement en leur proposant une
planification c'est-à-dire des objectifs
des moyens des actions et une méthode
claire malgré le choix du temps
législatif contraint qui finalement a
déroulé un tapis rouge à la guérilla
compte entier éolienne des amis
opportunistes de la biodiversité celles
et ceux qui d'ordinaires ne s'en
préoccupe guerre malgré cela nous avons
essayé de faire des propositions
nombreuses sur ce texte pour l'améliorer
car le réchauffement climatique est
prévisible et ses conséquences le sont
également nous aurions pu éviter de
telles tensions sur les prix de
l'énergie sur l'approvisionnement en
prévoyant cette planification ambitieuse
et efficace des énergies renouvelables
qui sont des énergies peu coûteuses et
disponibles mauvaise élève la France
doit revoir sa copie l'urgence
aujourd'hui demande beaucoup de courage
politique pour opérer le changement de
modèle énergétique les écologistes
avaient un a priori positif malgré un
texte dont nous ne partageions pas le
diagnostic ni le calendrier un
diagnostic qui tenait pour seul
responsable le code de l'environnement
pour expliquer la lenteur des projets
les raisons sont ailleurs mais force est
de constater qu'à ce stade le compte n'y
est pas
d'abord un mécanisme de planification
discutable il ne garantit pas
l'implication positive des territoires
clés de réussite du déploiement partagé
nous étions favorables à ce que le bloc
communal évidemment puisse proposer des
zones de développement mais nous
considérions aussi quand l'absence de
règles claires si les communes ne jouent
pas le jeu alors il doit y avoir une
décision à un autre niveau vous avez
refusé il y a eu des bas votre majorité
était partagée sur ce sujet et à ce
stade nous avons un dispositif qui
risque de freiner plutôt que d'accélérer
vous avez dit Madame la Ministre
préférée l'incitation à la contrainte
mais finalement l'incitation est faible
et la règle est si peu contraignante
nous demandions également
que le texte ouvre sur la question des
moyens pour faire la structuration des
filières la question des formations mais
le sujet a été envoyé à plus tard
comment se fait-il que des f notre
entreprise publique ne se soit pas
saisie des énergies renouvelables comme
un projet industriel que nous ne
sachions pas fabriquer des cellules
photovoltaïques dans notre pays fabriqué
DESMA organisé dès maintenant nous ne
lui en avons pas donné les moyens et on
dit ici ou là que les énergies
renouvelables pourraient sortir de notre
entreprise publique le développement de
ces filières c'est aussi de la valeur
ajoutée pour nos territoires nous
demandions une application plus forte de
la puissance publique et un modèle plus
coopératif du développement des énergies
renouvelables nous proposions un contrat
de service public ou un agrément de
service public cela n'a pas été adopté
nous voulions renforcer les communautés
locales d'énergie cela a été faiblement
proposé l'ambition pour nous était aussi
développée essentiellement les énergies
renouvelables sur les terres déjà
artificialisées nous réclamons une
ambition plus fort sur la solarisation
des toitures la version finale est moins
10 ans que celle du Sénat puisque
l'article constaire a été supprimé le
verre est à moitié vide est à moitié
vide avec quelques progrès mais un
résultat qui n'est pas satisfaisant à
contrario nous refusions le
développement des renouvelables là où la
biodiversité doit être pleinement
protégée et là où la souveraineté
alimentaire doit être garantie qu'il
s'agisse de l'application de la pire
version de la ripm l'article 4 ou qu'il
s'agisse de l'encadrement du
développement du photovoltaïque sur le
sol le compte n'y est pas vous nous avez
dit qu'il y avait un règlement européen
qui nous ont imposé nous l'avons lu relu
il y avait un compromis possible mais le
cafouillage ou la manœuvre pendant la
séance n'a pas permis d'étudier ses
compromis madame la ministre nous
l'avons dit répéter pour les écologistes
climat biodiversité souveraineté
alimentaire sont des combats de même
importance
certaines avancées doivent être
soulignées la création d'un observatoire
même si la version que vous avez proposé
au final est plus faible que celle que
nous proposions la création d'un
médiateur des énergies renouvelables de
timides avancées sur l'autoconsommation
une exigence qualitative sur la
méthanisation même si nous regrettons
l'introduction d'un amendement visant à
verdir du gaz de schiste américain en
prévoyant des garanties d'origine pour
le biogaz non injecté mais nous
pourrions citer aussi la modulation
tarifaire pour mieux répartir les
énergies renouvelables alors vous avez
dit 33 amendements c'est beaucoup mais
la quantité ne fait pas la qualité
finale du texte et puis c'est normal
dans un exercice de parlementarisme qui
a pu exister que des amendements soient
adoptés d'ailleurs certains contre votre
avis l'adoption de ces amendements ne
sont pas des cadeaux qui sont faits aux
oppositions c'est le rôle normal du
Parlement de participer à l'adoration
d'un texte nos points bloquants étaient
connus dès le début de l'étude du texte
c'est construit en responsabilité les
travaux de la commission mixte par
seront déterminants pour notre vote
finale la CMP peut revenir à un
équilibre meilleur sur la planification
sur le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables notre vote sera une
abstention c'est une abstention en
responsabilité et elle a une
signification politique
[Musique]
je vais
s'il vous plaît
je veux mettre au revoir le projet de
loi est-ce que chacun peut regagner sa
place
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
si alors
attendez s'il vous plaît moi j'ai un
résultat mais effectivement qui doit pas
correspondre au nombre de personnes que
je vois devant moi donc on va on va
relancer le vote et mes chers collègues
on se calme il y a un problème technique
ça sert à rien de s'énerver j'ai un
administrateur qui est à mes côtés et
qui essaye de résoudre le problème le
premier scrutin indiquait 315 votants
vous pouvez constater avec moi que vous
n'êtes pas 315 dans cette émission
monsieur Gosselin pour un rappel au
règlement
merci madame la présidente rappelle au
règlement là je ne sais même pas le
fondement mais en tout cas c'est sur
l'organisation des votes parce que je
crois parce que je crois que ce cas de
figure est assez unique en tout cas
récemment bref
nul ne conteste d'abord la présidence
mais nul ne conteste que nous sommes
plus de 315 ici effectivement mais mais
ce problème technique que vous soulevez
à l'instant lorsque mais c'est réglé
attendez monsieur banana je m'exprime
j'ai un rappel au règlement la
présidente m'a autorisé à parler donc
vous n'êtes pas président encore
laissez-la siéger et donc madame la
Présidente
lorsque les résultats lorsque les
résultats peuvent être à ce point serrés
que des majorités peuvent basculer ou
pas
quid de ces éléments techniques qui
aujourd'hui apparaissent mais mais bien
sûr que oui bien sûr que oui
bien sûr que oui là c'est flagrant mais
si on a un incident sur simplement
quelques votes je crois que le doute
peut être permis la question peut
peut-être se poser de temps en temps et
il faudra pouvoir y répondre il y a pas
de scandale il y a pas de manipulation
mais il faut absolument éviter toute
interprétation des résultats voilà
je vais être tout à fait transparente
avec vous le premier comme toujours le
premier vote qui s'est affiché était
avec 315 votants et il y avait une
adoption du texte là moi j'ai un vote
qui est exprimé sous mes yeux qui est
votre en 379 exprimé 350 de majorités
177 pour 198 contre 154 donc c'est le
deuxième vote que j'ai moi
mais vous êtes plusieurs à vous êtes
manifesté comme indiquant que vous
n'avez pas pu voter que ça n'a pas
marché donc moi ce que je vous propose
en toute simplicité et en toute clarté
c'est que nous recommençons les
opérations de vote à l'instant est-ce
que vous en êtes d'accord
[Applaudissements]
donc je vais vous annoncer le résultat
du scrutin sur le projet de loi relatif
à l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable je voudrais
vraiment remercier tous les services de
l'assemblée qui ont géré dans des
conditions pas faciles cet événement
complètement imprévu et bien sûr vous
mes chers collègues pour votre patiente
et nous essayons d'ores et des jeunes
avons mis les moyens en œuvre pour
rechercher les origines de la panne et
donc nous avons un nombre de votants de
562 personnes qui montrent bien que les
votes électroniques étaient défaillants
nombre de suffrages exprimés 524
majorité absolue 263 pour l'adoption
286 contre 238 donc l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi
madame la ministre si vous souhaitez
dire quelques mots
je vais dire quelques mots que j'avais
préparé pour un hébicycle un peu plus
rempli mais néanmoins merci d'abord
d'être revenu pour la proclamation des
résultats je voudrais tout d'abord vous
remercier de vous être largement
mobilisé sur ce texte nous avons eu des
débats importants pour l'avenir
énergétique de notre pays et la teinte
de nos objectifs de développement
d'énergie des carbonées parce que c'est
de ça qu'il s'agit rattraper notre
retard pour faire de notre pays la
première grande nation à sortir de sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles ce
projet nous permet de nous inscrire dans
la trajectoire extrêmement ambitieuse du
paquet climat européen
je voudrais saluer le travail inédit de
co-construction sur ce texte car je
crois qu'au terme de plus de 90 heures
de débats en commission en hémicycle
l'adoption de 645 amendements dont près
de la moitié venant des commissions donc
645 c'est la somme de la Commission
et de la séance
évidemment
on aura des jusqu'au bout
[Rires]
pas pressé on ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est horrible
nous pouvons
collectivement être fier de cet exercice
inédit de démocratie parlementaire
c'est horrible
et
je pense pouvoir dire que ce texte est
votre texte ce texte porte de nombreux
avancées qui vont permettre de réduire
de plusieurs années les délais de
développement non je vais pas pouvoir le
faire je suis désolé